what's going on today we're going to be
talking about key codes what are key
codes and how do we find them when a
vehicle is made by a manufacturer let's
say gmc or chevy that specific vehicle
has a unique key bidding to it a bidding
is the sequence of highs and lows of
cuts in that key when a manufacturer
makes a car based on their vin number
they assign a specific key code with a
specific bidding to that vehicle one
thing you should know about key codes is
multiple vehicles are made with the same
key code although it's highly unlikely
that you're going to come across two
vehicles with the exact same key code it
is very well possible many vehicles
require a leashi tool in order for us to
pick and decode the door lock but on
certain vehicles key codes can make the
process much quicker and more efficient
key codes can often be found engraved on
locks throughout the vehicle sometimes
they're on the door lock sometimes
they're on the ignition and sometimes
they're on the glove box many times
these locks are really easy to pull out
and just read that key code and with
that key code we can either plug it into
a database to convert it into bidding or
many key cutting machines today you can
just plug that key code directly onto
your machine and you can get the bidding
to spit out and all you have to do is
hit cut key and you have a working key
for the ignition common vehicle makes
where locksmiths will seek out a key
code is going to be for hondas toyotas
and gmc these three i'm constantly
looking for the key code for gmc all you
got to do is go through a process of
picking the ignition and popping that
ignition cylinder out once it's out you
can see there's an engraved key code on
that ignition which i just type right
into my machine and cut the key on
honda's that's another really common one
the glovebox locks usually just comes
out with a couple screws pull that out
and simply you can see the key code
written right on it every locksmith out
there needs to have a plan b sometimes
you can't get that door lock out you
can't get that ignition lock out or
maybe your leashing tool does not want
to cooperate that brings us to the next
way to get key codes a key code vendor
has databases where they have all the
vin numbers and all the key codes the
key code vendor that i use is rapid key
codes all i have to do is text over the
vin number and they respond with the
text and it has the key code usually it
only takes anywhere from like 5 to 20
minutes and i am cutting that key for
the customer it works as a great
alternative and i always have it in the
bag for a backup to sign up with rapid
key codes i'll have information in the
description on how to do so it's super
easy so if anybody has any questions
about key codes and how they work please
drop them in the comments like this
video and subscribe if you want to see
more locksmith content